there is a completely mind-blowing new
claim in a book which says that Robert
Muller felt so strongly that Donald
Trump had actually committed criminal
obstruction that Moeller drafted
indictment documents against Donald
Trump now eventually as we know Muller
punted on the issue of obstruction and
Donald Trump he said in his report that
although there was quote substantial
evidence of Donald Trump's obstruction
and I believe it was eight of the
possible 14 instances of obstruction for
political reasons robert muller decided
not to decide about indictment on
obstruction and sort of punted to donald
trump's hand-picked attorney general
william bar who obviously no surprise
said yeah we're not going to indict
donald trump but is the claim made in
the book true i don't know i'm gonna lay
it all out for you and maybe we can
figure it out this is from michael
Wolf's latest book now you might
remember Michael Wolfe wrote his
previous book fire and fury which had
all sorts of explosive claims about
Donald Trump and his administration and
the people around him some of which have
not been proven to be true or at least
have not been independently corroborated
outside of the book itself so we now get
to Michael Wolf's new book which is
called siege Trump under fire and what
Wolfe says is that Robert Muller had
actually drawn up a three count
obstruction of justice indictment
against President Donald Trump but that
eventually he didn't file it and the
Guardian asked a spokesman for robert
muller about this and mullux
miller spokesman is flat-out just saying
didn't happen and is quoted as saying
the documents that you've described do
not exist now that language is relevant
at least possibly and I'll get back to
that in a second let's talk about Wolf's
sources Wolfe cites internal documents
given to him by sources close to the
office of the Special Counsel okay now
what makes this claim not like other
random or particularly salacious claims
that have been made is that the
documents exist the Guardian has looked
at the documents that Michael Wolfe has
there is a document which Michael Wolfe
gave to the Guardian which says under
Title 18 US Code subsection 1505 that
the president the this is a draft
indictment the president is charged with
corruptly or by threats of force or
threatening communication influencing
obstructing or impeding a pending
proceeding before a department or agency
of the United States the second count in
this draft indictment that Michael Wolfe
looked at and showed to the Guardian is
a count under Section 1512 charging the
president with tampering with a witness
victim or informant the third count in
this document that the Guardian has
looked at is under section 1513 charging
Donald Trump with retaliating against
the witness victim or informant Wolfe
says that the documents claim that
Trump's obstruction started on day 7 of
his administration and Wolfe has endless
additional documents including a bunch
of internal memos about whether or not
the president can be indicted in the
consensus of those documents as that the
answer is yes so the question is are the
documents real is Muller spokesperson
lying when he denies the existence of
the documents are the documents fake if
they're fake who fake them is it Wolfe
is it whoever gave them to Wolfe is it
somebody else there has to be some
objective truth here either this is real
or it is not and it appears to be binary
except there is a sort of vocabulary
semantic possibility here if you look
again at the statement from Robert
Muller spokesperson he said quote the
documents described do not exist these
are lawyers okay
documents described do not exist that is
the present tense that is very different
than saying the documents never existed
the claim from Michael Wolfe is that the
documents existed they were drafted and
that they were scrapped that is one
possibility as to how everybody is
telling the truth there well could have
been a draft indictment against Donald
Trump it could have been scrapped and
therefore in a technical sense
Moeller spokes per
is right the documents do not exist
today May 29 29 teen there's another
possibility that the documents contained
four counts against Donald Trump and not
three technically that means that a
document containing three counts against
Trump doesn't exist but one containing
four or maybe two counts could exist
The Guardian looked at the documents and
they certainly aren't saying that the
documents are bogus
and we have the denial from Moeller
spokesperson which could potentially be
a very carefully crafted non denial I
don't know hopefully we'll know the
truth about these documents sometime
soon but the end result of all of this
is molars got to testify right molars
silence is a growing problem it seems he
may be sort of willing to testify before
the House Judiciary Committee if it's
behind closed doors but will he won't he
I don't know the growing questions
around this really make it necessary for
him to sit down and most importantly
remember what portion of the country has
read the Moller report is it 1% is it 2%
maybe 5% whatever that number is it's
way too low and Robert Muller testifying
ideally publicly would actually serve
the purpose of informing people about
what's in the report most of which
remains unknown to the majority of the
American population and that's why it's
so important that Muller testify that's
why it's so important that the house
formally start a debate about
impeachment to get the content of the
report out to more than just the I don't
know one two or five percent of the
American public that has read it let me
know what you think about these claims
by Michael Wolfe the documents the
Guardians review of the documents I
don't know what to think but I do think
it's possible that the documents are
real and that the denial from Muller
spokesperson has a very narrow meaning
that we should be interpreting I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I do want
to hear from you today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
that offers over 25,000 online courses
on almost any topic you can imagine
cooking meditation photography video
editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]